Kia ora.
What are you doing in here?
You're having a dream about New Zealand, my Australian friend...
...and I'm in it.
That makes sense.
I have been dreaming of going  to New Zealand.
Can I have a dream beard?
Yeah, sure. Let's go!
This is my favorite part!
Everyone in here is me.
Except for Di.
Kia ora, Di!
Kia ora, Ty!
She's doing another Australian's fresh crayfish dream.
I'm in another Aussie's dream?
It's actually quite a complicated complex crayfish crossover,...
...but if you don't think about it,...
...just pedal.
Pedal?
Lovely.
Are all kiwis that big?
Nah, that's a dream kiwi.
Don't look at it in the eyes!
My beard!
I don't want this dream to be over.
It doesn't have to be, my little hairless buddy!
Just book a ticket!
Come on, kiwi!